real mix thoughts about the Incredibles
my guess is this is because it was
bringing a lot of stuff to the big
screen that I want to see for a while
but maybe that got me a little too
overhyped
for example it's great seeing a
computer-animated film by Brad Bird
whose work I really enjoyed an Iron
Giant The Simpsons
hell even family dog it was great seeing
a comedic superhero movie which at the
time we only sort of got the tick and
maybe one or two other ones that didn't
really go anywhere so it was great
seeing an awesome team of writers from
Pixar take onto subject matter like this
I also like the idea that it's a
superhero family we haven't seen that
before and it allows for a lot of
creative characters and powers and
abilities and oh gosh this is just gonna
be awesome in the Golden Age of
superheroes mr. incredible is one of the
most famous how'd he get his superpowers
who cares they just exist and apparently
they exist for a lot of other
superheroes who apparently just have
superpowers it's cool I'll buy it
mr. uncredible gets married to
Elastigirl and it looks like they're
gonna live happily ever after being
superheroes with their secret identities
and so forth but then things go awry
when the people who are safe starts
suing the superheroes for property
damage physical health mental health all
sorts of American bullshit soon
everybody starts suing superheroes and
all the superheroes or supers as they're
called have to go into a protection
agency where they can't use their powers
at all mr. incredible is now mr. par and
he has started a family with mrs. par
they have three children who as you'd
expect also had superpowers while the
rest of the family for the most part
seemed to fit in ok without using their
powers mr. Parr is going through the
always popular midlife crisis he misses
the golden days the sense of adventure
hates being in an office and hates
turning people down in fact he even
performed superhero jobs on the side but
never lets his wife know things start to
change though when he gets a letter from
a woman named Mirage who has a ton of
secret missions lined up for him and
wants him to return to the glory days of
superhero hood mr. Parr agrees going
behind his family's back but little does
he know that a villain named Syndrome
it's actually planning the whole thing
it's nice to see Pixar film that
actually focuses on people
and what I like is that they don't try
to make them look like actual people
they try to make them look like 3d
cartoons Brad Bird always had great
designs for his animations and they show
here it doesn't look like something that
started being designed in a computer it
looks like it was drawn for it and then
turned into a 3d model that makes the
designs as well as the characters much
more memorable it's also nice to see
Pixar continue with its dramatic tone
Incredibles actually doesn't have as
many laughs as you would think it would
it focuses more on mr. pars midlife
crisis how all the colour is sucked out
of his world and how he wants a little
sympathy from his family whether it's
really deserving to him or not
but that's kind of my main problem with
the film the movie is called The
Incredibles but really it should have
been called mr. incredible and his
family because the focus is mostly on
him and to be honest you can kind get
the gist of ways going through and maybe
the first ten minutes the family gets
focused - but not until the last third
really and I like the family a lot I
like mrs. Parr I like - I like violet I
like that baby that has that psychotic
breakdown at the end I really wanted
more of them I wanted more of their
powers I wanted more of their
personality I want to see more of their
interactions and like I said we do get a
lot of them the last third but the
majority of it is dealing with mr. Parrs
midlife crisis and for me I think it
just has too much focus there's still
some redeeming qualities in the first
two-thirds though for example there's
this really great designer character
that's actually voiced by Brad Bird as
well she designs the costumes for the
family it's a lot of fun to seeing her
almost psychotic passion for what she
does but voice acting aside one of the
sad weaknesses of Brad Birds work is
that the stories are often a little
choppy as much as I love Iron Giant and
a lot of his other works I'll be the
first to admit that the narratives are
not very flowing I mean they work okay
and the characters I think are
ultimately what pulls it through but
they always seem to jump around a bit I
always feel one more rewrite would
probably make these films a little
stronger but again that's no way saying
that The Incredibles or as other films
are by any means failures they're not
the strongest point of the movie is the
last third where you see the powers
being used you see the family interact
and you see the comedy you see the
action you see the villain you see all
the stuff that you're waiting for and it
is well
worth the wait I only wish I could have
seen more of this in the first 2/3 I
think if they did that I probably would
have really loved this movie but for
what it is when it does get to the parts
that does really well it's a ton of fun
and it's smart and it's emotional and it
has good jokes I think Brad Birds
biggest strength is his connections with
families I love how the mother talks to
the kids very much like how a mother
would talk to her kids
even if it is a very bizarre setup I
also like the way he writes kids they're
very energized but they're insecure as
well they're troublemakers but they're
not stupid and they have a lot of
personality do I wish there was more
focus on them and mrs. Parr absolutely
but for what it is it's very
entertaining and very creative even if
it is a little inconsistent it's a good
film if you just manage to get through
some of the slower scenes and like I
said before it's great to finally see
Pixar branching out and actually working
with human characters they don't have to
keep the focus on creatures or toys or
materials that just come to life this is
opening a whole new door for ya
join me in the next review